Hello world, it's arrived and
everybody fails at some point.
The question is how do
you overcome this failure?
I'm going to recall five times in my life
where I failed big time and talk about
how I later recovered.
To give you some insight into ways
of overcoming failure in general.
One of my first big fails was fitting
into the modern American narrative.
What I mean is I was born in
Houston, Texas. Shout out to h town,
two parents from India and I
spent my formative years there.
I was born with the name Saroj and in
middle and high school I got made fun of a
lot in a racist way.
I also never saw any character in
American TV or movies that looked like me
doing cool stuff and it makes sense.
Indians had only started to migrate to
the states in the past couple of decades,
but I didn't feel like I fit in
with the Indian culture either.
I was never Indian enough for that
group. My family, of course loved me,
but I wanted that love and acceptance
from the kids at school and the ladies of
course. And I just never felt
it. I want it to be white.
I didn't want to be racialized,
Aka put into a box as that Indian
kid who did some great thing,
but instead I wanted to be that
so I legally changed my
name to Jason Scott Revelle.
The year before I went to College at
Columbia University in New York City,
I lightened my skin, changed my
style, tried to be a whole new person,
a fresh restart on life, but what I later
found was that nothing really changed.
I still didn't feel fully accepted and
introducing myself to Indian people
became awkward. Alf, as the years passed,
I learned to fully accept
myself for who I was.
I stopped trying to be what I thought
other people would like and instead
focused more on being the
best version of me. Sure.
I don't know anyone out there who's both
a wrapper and really into artificial
intelligence. Sure. It's not a normal
thing, but I'm not a normal person.
I'm a new breed and I'm going to bring
my abnormal reality into the mainstream
narrative and change culture.
I'll make a place for
myself and not as Jason.
I legally changed my name back
to Siraj and it was liberating.
When I focus on being true to myself.
I started to attract the right kind of
friends and finally felt that sense of
belonging that I always wanted.
My second big fail I had was my first
startup lucid robotics that I started as a
student at Columbia.
I was so manically obsessed with
building a robot to help the elderly with
chores.
I woke up every day really excited and
spent long nights in the robotics lab
planning next steps.
I managed to find a team of great people.
After countless interviews,
I managed to raise a seed round after
rejected by 30 or 40 venture capital firms
in New York and we managed
to build a working prototype,
but the market didn't want our product.
The team got disillusioned with the
idea and our investor lost hope.
Nine months of hard work and
I had nothing to show for it.
The worst part was that failing at the
startup made me slowly lose my passion
for robotics in a big way,
and I didn't know if it would come back.
I felt really lost and afraid.
I didn't know what I should do next,
but I did know that I didn't
want to dwell on this.
Failure to long San Francisco was a
place I'd always wanted to live in,
so I packed my things and moved to
a hacker house, 20 beds in one room.
It was gritty,
it was uncomfortable,
but it was me moving forward from failure
into a new environment of possibility
and as I met starry eyed
entrepreneurs there,
my passion for AI returned and I began
to search for new ways to have impact.
The third fail I had was getting
rejected from so many different jobs.
During my first fulltime job hunt in SF,
I made sure my resume looked
well formatted and impressive
and I use a bunch of
recruiting agencies to help me get
interviews for different startups in the
area.
But one by one I got rejection after
rejection and every time I would lose a
little bit of hope.
Meanwhile,
I had friends who seemingly easily
got jobs that really cool companies.
I didn't know what I was doing wrong.
Maybe I wasn't enthusiastic
enough during the interview.
Maybe I needed to study more,
maybe I needed to apply
for a different position.
It was really stressful,
but I found that since I ensured my body
and mind were healthy and that I kept a
positive attitude on life,
I preserved through all the
rejection until I got my first offer.
It's never easy rising
up the career ladder,
whether you go through a corporate
route or a startup route,
you continually build trust in
your own name brand by the brands,
Aka companies you've worked with
and things get easier as you go,
but you've got to put in that
initial effort to get your first gig.
No matter how many rejections you get.
At first.
My fourth fail was getting fired from
Twilio and this is the first time I'm
publicly admitting that when I first
landed the job as a developer educator at
Twilio,
I was delighted.
I learned so much in such
a short period of time.
Technical Writing wasn't some
chore that Developers had to do.
It was a craft,
a skill that can be honed over time.
A mix of math and programming and prose.
It was the perfect job for me.
I was writing Api docs in
multiple programming languages
for multiple products
that affected over a million developers.
I loved my team and what I did,
but near the end,
my performance started to drop.
I had the idea to make videos for
developers and my team at the time didn't
really think it was a good
idea to focus on that.
So I started my own youtube channel
to experiment with the idea.
I started dedicating more and more of
my time to that and my performance at my
job suffered as a result,
so I was eventually let go.
I gave myself a single week
to feel sorry for myself.
I felt like I'd let down so many people
who believed in me, but in that failure,
I found the opportunity to finally be
able to work on my youtube channel full
time. I was able to turn
that sorrow into excitement.
It was risky,
it was fun,
it was liberating and I
don't regret it one bit.
My fifth failure was actually multiple
little failures all the times I received
mostly negative comments when I
first started making youtube videos.
Some of my initial videos were really
low budget and I definitely got a lot of
criticism.
My close friends at the time sat me down
and told me it wasn't a good idea that
I should instead get a job at a cool
company or think of some B to B product
idea,
but I was so motivated by a mixture of
wanting to educate people and wanting my
own independence that
I kept at it defiantly.
I learned to take each negative
comment as crucial feedback.
I let the critics helped me mold and shape
the content so that it got better and
better every time.
I watched lots of youtube videos of people
who inspired me and made sure to stay
inspired.
Even during my darkest hours,
I didn't really know what it was
that I was doing. Was it a startup?
Was it a hobby?
All I knew is that I had a mission to
inspire and educate developers to build
AI,
and that's what kept me going no
matter how silly I looked on camera and
eventually the channel
grew to what it is today.
It's been just over two years since I
started this youtube channel because of
it. I've had the opportunity to
speak at the United Nations cern,
a bunch of conferences all over the world.
I taught a deep learning
course at u Udacity.
I made a video for Elan Musk.
So many awesome things have happened and
I've just started what's turning out to
be a very successful company,
the school of Ai,
if I can do great things. So can you,
so get to it wizard. I'm here for you.
The winner of last week's coding challenge
is how much shake Ahmad used a really
cool data set to predict whether or not
students would get probation in their
second year, and he use logistic
regression to do this great work.
And the runner up is blahdy.
Blahdy also used a logistic regression
model built in num Pi to predict whether
or not there was breast cancer
in some patients. Amazing work.
Please subscribe for more
programming videos. And for now,
I've got to explore Lisbon,
so thanks for watching.